[Música]
eeuu y el grupo talibán entabla en los
primeros diálogos desde la toma de kabul
en agosto pasado instalados en qatar
discuten la evacuación de los
extranjeros que quedan el suelo a cano
la ayuda humanitaria y una eventual
cooperación para combatir al estado
islámico tendremos invitado especial
renuncia del primer ministro de austria
sebastián curso en medio de un caso de
corrupción en el que se le investiga el
mandatario dimitió en un intento por
salvar la coalición de gobierno entre
los conservadores y los verdes francia
luchará por abolir la pena de muerte en
todo el mundo según anunció el
presidente de manuel mayo a propósito de
esto hablaremos de cuál es la situación
de este castigo en américa donde eeuu es
el único que sigue ejecutando
prisioneros
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 yo soy maría
clara calle por primera vez desde agosto
el gobierno estadounidense y el grupo
talibán se sientan cara a cara para
negociar varios temas por un lado eeuu
quiere terminar las evacuaciones
mientras que el talibán insiste en
mantener las ayudas humanitarias
internacionales esto ocurrió un día
después de que el estado islámico
perpetrar a un ataque suicida en el
norte de afganistán está con nosotros
desde santiago guido larsson experto en
terrorismo y analista en seguridad
internacional él es el director del
instituto de humanidades de la
universidad del desarrollo en chile
bienvenido a france 24 señor larsson qué
implica esta reunión que están teniendo
en doha
implica algo que es bastante fácil de
prever o de haber previsto antes del
retiro estados unidos es bastante
pragmático cuando tiene que defender
parte de sus intereses entiende que la
situación de seguridad interna en
afganistán es muy problemática sobre
todo con vistas a la salida de miles de
refugiados fuera del país entiende
también de que los talibán tienen
algunas diferencias de orden ideológica
con otras organizaciones competitivas y
por lo tanto solamente le interesa
levantar un emirato en su propia zona
territorial y por esa misma razón forma
parte de
focos de esfera de enemistad de otras
organizaciones como el grupo del estado
islámico y sabe también que estas otras
organizaciones tienen como una de sus
metas principales realizar atentados
contra eeuu y sus aliados y por lo tanto
frente a dos escenarios relativamente
negativos la toma de poder de los
talibanes y al mismo tiempo el escenario
de seguridad pero que eeuu está tomando
una decisión pragmática requiere
negociar para incrementar su propia
seguridad para garantizar de que
ciudadanos estadounidenses o bienes
ciudadanos que forman parte de su esfera
de influencia puedan salir de afganistán
y lograr contener a lo que son las
organizaciones que realmente tienen una
perspectiva más internacional en el
ámbito del desarrollo esos atentados
como el estado islámico
usted nos estaba hablando un poco de la
situación de seguridad en afganistán y
el aumento también de los atentados
suicidas y esto pone en duda la promesa
del talibán de preservar la seguridad en
afganistán que tan importante cree usted
que es esto para la comunidad
internacional
es crucial por dos razones la número uno
es puramente publicitaria o medio
comunicacional en el sentido de que todo
atentado que ocurra dentro de afganistán
más allá de que forme parte de una
lógica en la cual llevamos inserto
durante 20 años va a animar la
perspectiva de que la situación de
inseguridad es mucho peor de lo que
realmente se piensa esto tiene que ver
un poco con la dinámica del terrorismo
el terrorismo es muy espectacular y
tiene este elemento de teatralidad de la
propia violencia del propio propio
terror por lo tanto también hay un
elemento como esto se percibe desde el
punto de vista internacional pero sin
lugar a dudas afganistán forma parte de
un foco de seguridad es muy importante
no solamente porque por afganistán se
produce por ejemplo una parte muy
sustantiva de el mercado de los opioides
sino porque también es foco de atracción
de organizaciones que comparten algún
tipo de relación de orden e ideológica y
en ese sentido tanto para estados unidos
como para la unión europea y algunos de
sus aliados
estabilidad interna de afganistán es
clave independientemente de quien esté
tomando el poder
señor larsson muchas gracias por
explicarnos este panorama y la
importancia que tiene afganistán en la
seguridad internacional y como
mencionamos anteriormente en el
autodenominado estado islámico perpetró
el viernes un atentado suicida en una
mezquita de la ciudad de kunduz hoy se
llevarán a cabo los funerales de las
víctimas la mayoría de las familias de
las al menos 46 personas asesinadas
despidieron hoy a sus seres queridos en
un funeral masivo el ataque dejó a de
más de 100 heridos y puso al descubierto
la preocupante situación que enfrentan
la minoría chiíta en el país
cambiamos de continente y vamos a europa
porque el canciller de austria sebastián
course renunció en medio de una
investigación en su contra por
corrupción course dimite para evitar una
crisis gubernamental el caso también
involucra a su círculo más cercano de
colaboradores y a su partido popular vp
esta colectividad gobierna con los
verdes desde que curso asumió como
primer ministro en enero de 2020 aunque
se estimó que los ecologistas podrían
aliarse con la oposición ya confirmaron
que la coalición de gobierno continuará
el ministro de relaciones exteriores
alexander schallenberg respaldado por el
partido de course podría ser el nuevo
canciller
y nuestra tarea
me gustaría acceder el espacio para
salir del estancamiento y para evitar el
caos y garantizar la estabilidad de sus
ideales
yo le pedí al equipo de gobierno del
partido popular que definitivamente
continúe el trabajo y como presidente
del partido popular el partido con más
votos el propuesto a aleksandar salen
ver como el nuevo jefe de gobierno del
presidente
por primera vez desde la segunda guerra
mundial el partido comunista de
república checa perdió las elecciones
parlamentarias con el 99,9 por ciento de
los votos contados la oposición de
centroderecha de la coalición juntos
venció al partido del primer ministro
andrei baby a pesar de que los
oficialistas llevaban la ventaja juntos
a con menos de un punto porcentual de
ventaja pero al unirse con los liberales
también de oposición tendrán la mayoría
con 108 escaños el primer ministro
felicitó a sus rivales políticos
y en irak prima del ausentismo entre
jóvenes para las elecciones legislativas
anticipadas que se celebran este fin de
semana pese a los esfuerzos de las
autoridades por incentivar el voto los
electores manifiestan su decepción con
la clase política dirigente y dicen que
los comicios no son creíbles estas
votaciones responden a las protestas de
2019 marinas ardilla tiene más
información
a botar conduce a la realización de tus
demandas repetían a través de unos
altavoces las fuerzas de seguridad
iraquíes en un intento para incentivar
el voto en los comicios legislativos que
se celebrarán este domingo en irak y que
están marcados por el descontento social
y la desconfianza política
yo no votaré porque los resultados no
serán creíbles no creo que estas
elecciones sean libres y honestas y no
creo que un iraquí honorable pueda ser
candidato entre otros grupos porque
todos son unos fracasados y no aman a su
país ni son leales sino que quieren
regalarlo
la corrupción y la mala gestión de los
partidos tradicionales han hecho que
miles de iraquíes se nieguen a acudir a
las urnas mientras los expertos
pronostican que la clase política
mantendrá su control del poder por
los resultados de las elecciones
iraquíes se conocen y es un juego en el
que las clases políticas se turnan y se
reparten los ministerios entre ellos así
como el primer ministerio la presidencia
del parlamento y la presidencia está
claro cada cuatro años rotan
las elecciones se celebran un año antes
de lo previsto debido a las masivas
protestas antigubernamentales que
sacudieron el país en 2019 cuando
millones de jóvenes salieron a las
calles para exigir mejoras democráticas
y una salida al desempleo y el
desmoronamiento de los servicios
públicos dos años después la situación
sigue siendo precaria
los jóvenes son los más perjudicados en
este país especialmente por el gobierno
a nosotros nos mataron durante las
protestas y los recién licenciados están
en paro
más de 3400 candidatos compiten por 329
escaños en el parlamento en lo que son
los quintos comicios desde la invasión
estadounidense de irak en 2003 sin luz
está la capital de líbano los apagones
en beirut se incrementaron desde que las
dos centrales eléctricas más importantes
se quedaron sin combustible para operar
esto afectó principalmente a la
población más vulnerable que no tiene
dinero suficiente para pagar suministros
privados de energía la red eléctrica
libanesa no funcionará sino hasta dentro
de varios días la escasez de diesel y
gasolina agravó la crisis energética
enfrenta el país desde hace años donde
los cortes de luz son comunes por una
infraestructura de poca calidad
y en la isla española de la palma el
volcán cumbre vieja tiene tres nuevas
curadas porque la cara norte del cono de
la erupción se derrumbó una de las lavas
arrasó con un número reducido de casas
por su parte las autoridades canarias
hacen un llamado a la calma y sostienen
que la reciente actividad volcánica no
representa ningún peligro para los
habitantes algo a santana nos cuenta más
al respecto
los ríos de lava se han convertido en
una imagen cotidiana en la palma desde
el 19 de septiembre el volcán de cumbre
vieja no ha cesado su actividad pero el
sábado con la ruptura de su cara norte
las coladas incrementaron llevándose por
delante varias casas de la localidad de
todo que vivimos pueden casa encerrado
pero el terrenito que tenían todos nos
llevó a la montaña
los recuerdos de mi padre
pero diría que ya se sabrá todo esto ya
de una vez por todas que no seguir
haciendo daño porque es que cada vez
está haciendo más años pasando por zona
que se pensaba que no iba a pasar y está
pasando a pesar de los numerosos
movimientos sísmicos a raíz de la
actividad volcánica este sábado las
autoridades locales decidieron reabrir
el aeropuerto de la isla y aseguraron
que las coladas actuales no representan
un peligro en este momento con las
cantidades de lava y la posición y
movimiento de la colada no estamos en
necesidad de hacer todo eso puesto que
ya tenemos todo lo que está por debajo
evacuado entonces también pido en ese
aspecto tranquilidad y estar siempre
atento a las indicaciones que hagan las
autoridades de protección civil desde
que el volcán entró en erupción su lava
ha engullido al menos 480 hectáreas de
tierra en la palma
de 1100 edificios junto a la evacuación
de cerca de 6000 personas
el presidente francés emmanuel majo dijo
que su país lanzará una campaña para
abolir mundialmente la pena de muerte
esto lo hará cuando ejerza la
presidencia rotatoria de la unión
europea durante el primer semestre de
2022 bajo hizo la afirmación en la
conmemoración del aniversario 40 de la
abolición del castigo en francia aseguró
que trabajará con otros estados miembros
para lograr una resolución de la onu que
le pida a los países que informen año a
año el número de condenas a muerte que
dictan y las ejecuciones
[Aplausos]
y precisamente para seguir con este tema
de francia y su campaña para abolir la
pena de muerte una de las regiones donde
menos se practica es américa de hecho
eeuu es el único país del continente que
sigue ejecutando prisioneros conversamos
de este tema previamente con luís
fernando astudillo docentes de derecho
penal y filosofía en la universidad
metropolitana del ecuador nos explicó
por qué hay tan pocos de estos castigos
en el continente
se debe en gran parte a la nueva ola de
constitucionalismo que nosotros tenemos
en américa latina a partir de los años
1990 incluso con la firma de cartas
democráticas en los periodos post
dictadura pero yo creo que como américa
latina no debemos confiarnos tanto
porque una nueva ola o nueva corriente
de populismo penal cada vez se hace cada
vez nosotros vemos más discursos a favor
de la pena de muerte aunque tal como
usted le ha dicho no se encuentra
implementado debido al enorme aumento de
la criminalidad común en los países de
américa latina si bien es cierto q va y
venís todavía mantienen la pena de
muerte no se trata de un sistema penal
un sistema jurídico que deba
considerarse como un ejemplo para los
demás países en la región por lo general
se toma siempre como ejemplo los eeuu
sin embargo aún este país ha demostrado
que se trata de un sistema penal
imperfecto cuantas gratificaciones de
inocencia a través de juicios de
revisión no conocemos nosotros en eeuu y
lo único que le queda hacer al gobierno
es una compensación económica manera de
reparación y nada más lo que demuestra
que la pena de muerte en todo el sentido
de la palabra tiene efectos
irreversibles
en noticias del continente africano la
religiosa colombiana gloria cecilia
narváez fue liberada en mali ella había
sido secuestrada en 2017 por el frente
de liberación de máquina un grupo
yihadista vinculado a al-qaeda hoy la
presidencia de ese país confirmó su
liberación y resaltó la valentía y el
coraje de la monja el mandatario
interino así migoya afirmó que hubo un
esfuerzo de varios servicios de
inteligencia por su parte la canciller
de colombia martha lucía ramírez señaló
que el mandatario de este país iván
duque se reunió personalmente con varios
líderes africanos para buscar la
liberación
y terminamos con música clásica la
décima sinfonía de beethoven fue
completada con inteligencia artificial
esta es la única sinfonía que el
compositor alemán no alcanzó a terminar
antes de morir en 1827 ahora para
conmemorar su aniversario de nacimiento
número 250 que se cumplió en el 2020 un
equipo de musicólogos y programadores
desarrolló un algoritmo que jugó con los
fragmentos que ya existían y luego el
algoritmo improviso este fue el
resultado
con estas imágenes y música despedimos
nuestra emisión informativa continúen
cada media hora para más información en
france 24
y